all right Rob Rob where you from where'd
you grow up Buffalo tell me about your
family growing up you had both your
parents um when I was a kid my dad was a
truck driver so he wasn't at home very
much but he ended up passing away in a
work accident so um my mom raised me and
then my little brother he's my half
brother and um we're 15 years apart so
he's older he's younger he's younger so
when my mom passed away not long ago I
had to end up finishing raising him
until he finished high school and
everything and um with the drug problems
so my mom pass sudden in and with the
drug problems and being bipolar it was
hard to do so I had to let my aunt take
over at the very end of it so who's
bipolar your mom or you
are well actually it's my it runs into
my family on my mom's side so so your
mom is bipolar she acted it but she
didn't
get classified that my aunt her her Aunt
did and my cousin her daughter
did and you were bipolar as well I am
bipolar
yes when was that diagnosed um when my
father passed away I started having to
go to a
psychiatrist and I was probably 12 or 13
when they said I was bipolar cuz it was
kind of hard hard to distinguish between
teen rebellion and being bipolar mhm so
that's when they diagnosed
me and your drug
use does that help with it
or is that yourself it actually does it
does um I think a lot of it too is that
if I don't have it though I tend to be
Mor manic if I'm ever without drugs that
I cuz right now I don't even have to
have them but um if I search for them or
something that's something to do with
bipolar um we have like sometimes a one
track mind so if we set our mind to
something if we don't accomplish it it's
a feels like a little 80hd sort of like
I have to do
it and you've been in Los Angeles for
how long for two years
now you're on the streets yeah I'm
standing in a tent with a friend right
know here in
skidrow yeah
yeah what do you think of skidrow um
it's it's different than what I had
first thought it was going to be because
I heard about it before I came out here
and um it just seemed like a good idea
everybody's going to California living
in tents and it's going to be all all
right but it's uh it's not all right it
the ethnicity um there's a lot of
racism and um you're a minority down
here I do feel like that yeah um that
people's either talking Spanish or it's
the ethnic black kind of and I'm not a
racist guy I like black people so but
the way that they're on portraying their
themselves
they're it almost seems like a show a TV
show yeah in some ways it is you know
yeah and crystal meth is your drug I
yeah when I moved out here I tried fety
for the first time and I do it every now
and then oh so you use fentanyl too yeah
the crystal meth is your main um that in
marijuana how do you support yourself I
I get gr right now and I'm trying to get
back on my disability I was on it since
I was 18 and I'm 37 now your disability
is what um bipolar oh being bipolar yeah
um I'm allowed to work a certain amount
of hours a week but on it's it's full
disability but you're allowed to show
that you can work a little bit each week
and stuff how bad was your bipolar
disorder it is if I don't have medicine
it's extremely um depressive and um
manic depressive and then when we have
our extreme highs we have the extreme
highs like with with methamphetamine it
doesn't make me high it does what does
your behavior look like when you're not
dedicated um
withdrawn
um I don't really I don't talk to myself
or anything like that like schizophrenic
but I'm in my head thinking a
lot is that get in the way of employment
and yeah um it being bipolar you have a
not times out 10 a extreme dislike of
someone who tries to have authority over
you that's why it was hard growing up
having my mom as the uh parent only
parent it was hard on her too when she
would try to discipline me it and with
having managers or bosses for us to take
Direction it's hard for us to do it's
almost like a kid has to say no you know
when the parent says no the kid goes
ahead and does it it's like when the
boss tells you to do something you don't
do it and it's ingrained
in it's just part of your behavior
mhm but with medicine
I'm extremely better have you been
medicated professionally before um like
in a hospital yeah well I was I was
hospitalized twice and but where a
doctor gave you medication that helped
your bipolar disorder yeah I I get
prescribed tryal now it's uh a seizure
medicine and a bipolar medicine and are
you taking it currently yes you are MH
and you take crystal meth on top of that
yeah yeah it doesn't really interfere
with it but um I don't do it very often
I do mostly marijuana and um the Fetti
is what's been my fallback on
lately so the crystal meth has been
extremely less than when I
first well it's been probably a couple
months now and your fentanyl is
increasing yeah we I tend to substitute
one for the other because I started into
drugs with alcohol and I don't even
hardly ever drink
now a lot of people will replace one
addiction with another yeah like crystal
meth will replace crack very often and
fenal will replace everything yeah it's
extremely different from taking pain
pills cuz I had been on uh opiates at
one time and then I got put on suboxin
and it was all right but I think they
changed the um formula and the suboxin
to where now it doesn't do nothing for
me so I had to go back to
drugs
so but you're homeless you're living in
a tent on skid road that that's not
something anyone would choose to do yeah
is that a product of the drug use or is
that a product of being bipolar or um
it's I think all of it plays into it um
the situation where I went went from
having my mother as kind of an overseer
over my social security check and then
when she passed away I quit sending in
who my doctors were and when I quit
sending in who my doctors were they just
discontinued it and it was through New
York and everything so and the during
the process of moving out here I tried
to get it at another state along the way
and they denied me because of me being
through Alabama um New York then Alabama
denied me and then it was uh Arkansas
denied
me you have friends here on SK road that
you're in tent with my my friend Jeff
but I just recently started getting to
know him I moved out here not knowing
anyone it's dangerous down here no it is
dangerous
extremely that's what I was saying with
e ethnicity issues um I tend
with the bipolar I tend to stay more
withdrawn but especially in
this living style and situation and with
the neighbors for who they are they're
all right there there's good people out
there but you can walk by somebody and
just say the wrong thing or look at
someone in this area and it is total
flipping out on you curing like a lot of
it is religiously um entwined into their
grind into their minds to where um as
soon as something's wrong or if you're
looking at them it's about religion and
um I've noticed that a lot about uh a
lot of people in drugs that they'll it's
uh religiously entwined yeah well I
think the mental illness is what you see
most often yeah where that's that's in
play and then the drugs make it worse
yeah you have no family um I have my
little brother he's my half brother and
I have a couple of aunts and uncles that
are still living but I don't have any
contact with my family really what other
problems did the bipolar disorder cause
uh just relationships oh yeah
um
paranoia uh in
relationships it I would be skeptical of
almost everything and friendships I I
tend to do good
but with the relationships I'm skeptical
of Cu I've been I've been cheated on so
many times too and um a lot of it I
believe had to do with my bipolar um or
my mental state because I felt like I
wasn't good enough for them and um being
cheated on a few times it really doesn't
help with your building up the
self-image and so that helped tear me
down into where I I now act out in a
relationship to where I'm vocal I want
to see your phone and all that and I
shouldn't be that way but I feel a lot
of it is bipolar makes having a romantic
relationship very difficult it does and
I'm very
private and that so that's strange for
me to be that way and not see well I see
it I see that it's not fair but um
that's just how I I'm like well I know
I'm not doing it so you're going to show
me if you are you know do you find
yourself doing things to combat your
bipolar
behavior um I feel like I feel when a
manic State's coming on like a a low or
a high and I I'll get drugs for that
reason you'll get high and that will
that'll um feel make me feel stable I'm
like oh I'm going to be depressed soon
or something and so I'll get something
to make me feel happier or you'll see it
coming in the uh
yeah the drugs will help yeah
well are you afraid this is going to
turn into
a a situation you can't get yourself out
of I feel like
I'm at that situation but not at that
situation because it doesn't impact my
life
to to the DraStic um step step
of I'm losing out really I feel like
because I'm at the right bottom really
so um
but I feel
like me doing it has become such a norm
I wouldn't feel normal unless I did do
it so I feel like I'm at that stepping
point now or been that way this has
become your new normal it's been a
normal since I was a young um young
adults how old are you now 37 37
mhm yeah this is going to be what's your
biggest fear
now well it's so it's became the what
happened is uh being alone that's the
biggest fear and I am you
know seem to have a tendency to create
our worst
fears
yeah you have any goals or anything
you'd like to see happen in the next
five years I was I came out here cuz I
I'm I like to sing and I was going to
look into acting
so yeah it's going to be hard for you
living this very unstable life to yeah
to ever do
that uh it was a lot different I pictur
it in my mind coming out here than
what everything turned out to be thank
goodness for the refresh spot and stuff
like that they'll get let you take
showers and everything having a tent so
that's a good that's a good thing
so um cleanliness isn't that big of an
issue with what where I'm at
but living in a tent for a year is
nothing that is should be I mean people
have lived in tents you know like Nomads
and all that but that's just not my
lifestyle anymore you know emotionally
what do you go
through um it's a lot more draining um
tiring and depressive being
in sko than it is if I were living back
home with my mom and all that and Rob
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life be
mindful and kinder to the ones around
you cuz you never know when they get
took from you or when you'll burn the
last bridge for who you know and who
would really have been there for
you all right Rob thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you wish you
the best of luck out
here